[Music]
I shoulda tried to be more ordinary
he would never own Miriam saw the movie
in the first thing first
I just want it can I just give you a hug
real quick it's better I had to come
give you a hug I mean jeez your life I
know I didn't I don't think a lot of
people understand how the things that
you have been through in your life and
your search for any of it - that's a
20-year I mean I haven't seen a movie
but I know what's in it and there's a
lot of stuff that went on in 20 years I
mean how did we survive but we did you
two have formed more than just a
friendship a real bond happy I'll be
hanging short okay in the process yeah
yeah yeah what do you love about this
man and what have you learned about him
I have been a fan of Elton for as long
as I can remember I sang your song when
I was 17 audition for Raja and I've
loved the idea and plays in Bernie's
music forever but it's only since we've
become friends and I have found out how
interested and kind and curious and
caring and full of love and concern he
is that I've fallen in love with him as
a person he is intuitive in the extreme
and one of the kindest people I know and
it works both ways because I'm obviously
a lot older than Tara but we're very
much alike artists are very much alike
in a lot of way they can be very
self-destructive
they can be very moody and they can give
and often shop themselves away and we
both have the ability to do that so um I
you know I'm my ambition in life now is
to make sure he doesn't make the same
mistakes as I did can we talk about some
of those mistakes that are in the movie
I had no idea I'm in Dodger Stadium last
week and I see the picture of you with
the baseball bat and it's such an iconic
moment that everybody loves but just I
mean just days before that okay two days
before doctors tell me my stomach pumped
I took an overdose um there I was two
days later on Dodger Stadium with Cary
Grant and Billie Jean Kay and having the
time of my life you can say that I'm
resilient and that's one thing I am I'm
resilient and I wasn't none of the pass
or the opportunity of playing that great
stadium for two days by the way the
Dodgers were plane
well and it was just an amount it was
the highlight of my career to play
Dodger Stadium are you kidding me but I
was not mentally well before that
obviously but you know as a performer
form is very resilient and they come up
I come onstage and they do they do their
bit and they do it well you have to
that's what you do your performer and
that's what saved my life being a
performer being a teacher thinks he's
good enough for a scholarship really you
think he's got that kind of talent of
course he has but you'd know that if you
took the slightest bit of interest in me
or this family Bryce Dallas Howard is
brilliant in this movie also
but she's so one of the nicest people in
the world but so damn mean in this movie
you look at her and you say wow this is
it shocks you her performance is great
though I don't know I mean well you're
on what you know a new idea why she's
fantastic in the movie and she brings
very specific energy you know Alton has
spoken a lot about his he had a tricky
relationship with his parents and and
Brice is you know she she fulfills that
role very very well because that's why
think we're a lot of your problems stem
from if I may say so myself that's the
product of a very unhappy marriage and
you know the sad thing is my mom and my
dad married the wrong people they
shouldn't hurt each other and the great
thing about when they finally spit up
man you know one day I've weighed on how
to do what they found happiness which
I'm so happy about they both found the
partner they should have had before
although thank the Lord they made that
mistake yeah it was you know I mean in
those days in the 50 was a different
attitude very conservative so when
people were gonna get divorced it was
considered to be an outrage
oh please don't tell the neighbors and
make sure the neighbors don't know that
was what it was like and they honestly
stayed together much longer for my
education I appreciate that but it was
tough because every time they got
together they will argue about me but
the great thing is that after they did
divorce
they found happiness I'm I'm really
pleased about
[Music]
Taron you recorded Rocketman but is
there another any other the songs that
kind of seeped into your soul because
there are so many moments in this movie
where you are singing the songs and we
feel this like weird you feel this weird
back and forth that you remember you
performing that song in that moment I'd
love to consumption for different
reasons I have to say I think in our
movie your song is a bit of it is a bit
of a triumph as a storytelling moment
because it's a moment of tonight is
culture it is one of them it is a moment
where you're sitting in the movie you're
like that's actually largely I'm the one
singing but it's actually largely down
to Jamie Bell's work as well he's a
beautiful scene partner in that bit of
the movie and he pays attention
wonderfully and it's a real it's a real
moment of a real celebration of Alton
and Bernie's friendship and I feel very
very very proud of it so I would say
that that moments in that song and he's
I've listened I haven't seen the movie
but I've heard the music
and he's done the most phenomenal job
with the music son you know as songs are
not easier to sing they're not they're
quite complicated they're they're not
straightforward songs don't let the Sun
go down any tiny dancer aren't
straightforward songs saying and the
more he started singing the better he
got and Giles Martin who of course is
George's son is the musical director on
the whole film and encouraged him to
loosen up do the rock songs and he's
just he sing seems like a marina Hercule
is Saturday night so brilliantly [ __ ]
back on and he really put every fiber of
his body into that into the scene level
and the acting I mean he's worked double
hard he's done the singing and Heath on
the actor and I wanted this movie I
didn't want someone to be lip-syncing
I'm not taking away from any other
movies but I wanted someone to sing so
you were more convinced and I'm hoping
when I see the final thing tonight I
know the music is fantastic
and I know people have told me that it's
seamless the music lives the movie from
scene to scene but his music but what
I've heard is quite unreal
no it's phenomenal um we are right
outside you've shot I'm still standing
and in this movie you get a sense of
what that song really means now now that
you think back is it a miracle that you
are still standing that you're here
today my life has been America
and it's been a series of serendipity
and luck good fortune and brave
decisions but sitting here in this room
now the movie is showing tonight
premiering for the first time and I know
I'm still telling is probably the last
scene in the movie it is surreal because
what I tried to do to myself I shouldn't
be sitting here and I've been very very
lucky and the fact that I suddenly
realized that I had two choices one was
to die one was to live and it took me 16
years to IELTS for help it's a safety
word I need help because I was so proud
I knew had a problem was like wow I have
a problem at big time and I was very
unhappy with myself so I was ashamed of
myself but those three words I'm saying
to everyone out there if you have a
problem and you're unhappy and your side
in your lonely find out someone ask them
for help they will help you people help
me straight away and I was so bowled
over by kindness and people wanting to
get my life back on track I just do a
lot of work myself but people are so
kind and so fantastic so I saved my life
and Here I am sitting in the place above
the place where we shot that iconic
scene in the video yeah no really yeah
but I still feel like a little kid movie
I was like I gotta give you a high yes
I'm 72 years old I still feel like a kid
I still have a lot of energy and I know
I'm the luckiest man of the world I'm on
the biggest world tour of my life I have
this film coming out but everyone said
he's amazing I know it I hope and pray
that it gets a great reaction but even
if it doesn't I know that we probably
have made the film that we sell out to
me and that's all that counts and so
this year is amazing I have the Lion
King tell me out yeah how about that and
then I have a book coming out it's all
in the 70 second year seventy third year
of my life this is the biggest day of my
career oh I'm very happy this man has
been such an important part of it and
Dexter Fletcher who directed it jaws
lion and moralist all the actors in the
film Richard man Brice Howard Jamie Bell
everyone in the cast I think
from the bottle my heart and David
Furnish and Matthew one who produced the
film I've done the most amazing job by
the way
you talk about all the actors but really
this is also about your relationship
with Bernie and you do such a great job
of showing the magic of that
relationship how did you guys work on
that on the set well it was one of the
first things I asked Alton when we first
met you know what was it like when you
first met Bernie and I'll never forget
what Helen said he said it was like
meeting the brother I never had I had
someone to go to the cinema with and I
always say this lady's mad that once
upon a time Elton John didn't have to go
to the cinema with and I found that to
be a very inspiring relationship aside
from all of the beautiful music I just
think that friendship and that brother
that that brotherly love between them
was a was it as an exciting relationship
to build and Jamie Bell was the perfect
choice for now yeah we've been together
over 50 years and we have never had an
argument um there were times when we
took a distance for myself because he
needed to take distance from me well I
never thought that we would never come
back together because we were still
friends
it I'm so proud of my relationship with
him I love him more now than I did when
I met him which says a lot because in
this business you know you can get
knifed in the back you know there's not
much loyalty but to have that
relationship and to be celebrating this
relationship of mine and his 50 years
along the line he does the glue that
held me together I don't understand how
you sit at a piano though and take those
words and make those words in the meadow
do I oh I don't I have no idea it's just
it's just happenstance and serendipity
but if he gives me a lyric and I sit
down I look at the mirror I read it
through it and there's a little film
comes in my head and then I start put my
hands on Helen off we go and so I have
no idea it's a god-given thing and I'm
not even never thought about it it
freaks me out thing it well what we'll
be able to do at this time but I never
failed to be able to write to do it for
those of you who don't know in Rocket
Man I don't see anything Taran has
recorded we recorded all the songs that
are in the movie your radio show yeah it
is a I don't know if everyone discovered
it Taron was on it it's a great
interview and you guys go
little music but you have an eclectic
mix of different people you find
different artists and you you've
embedded all these new young artists in
your age well we started just at my
200th show in two days ago I'll record
it we started it with Apple and I said
listen I just want to play the music
that I want to play I just want to play
great music I don't want to have a this
is my show so I'm choosing the music so
what I do every month they send me all
the new music that they have and then I
buy my own CDs too and I write the CDs
that they don't have on the lift down
because they have more of the poppy
things and I have more the more
intricate thing we sit down together as
Charlie from my office comes over we go
through all the new music we say yay or
nay and then I play my music and say
what do you think and then I put them
all together and we do four shows at a
time which is for one hour shows and it
is the most fun you can possibly have
because there's so much great music out
there by so many young artists and we
know we started playing Billy Eilish a
colleague people like that agent
krystine in the coin before they even
became successful and then you see them
become successful and you think yeah I'm
so happy for you guys because you know I
could see that talent hadn't and at an
early age at their early age and I'm
able to help them i FaceTime to people
week this week I did Liz oh oh was so
fantastic I love you Liz oh and a boy
called Jacob Leventhal who's from New
York who boasts beautiful song and no
one's heard of him really yet but they
will and and you get to FaceTime people
and become friends with them Brandi
Carlile ago I knew anyway but I was able
to FaceTime allocating much better to
the whole program with me yeah q-tip did
a whole program with me he did one Brian
from the killer did one great music
Jenna I turned me on to some people it's
fun and it's you know if you don't keep
up with the young you're dead you have
to look at new movies new music listen
to new music
read new books senior artists
photographers because when you find
something new it inspires you I know all
the great old stuff it's in my head it's
in my computer and I love it it makes me
happy but it doesn't make me as happy as
when I hear something new that I say
Billy eyelid or lizzo or
I'll leave or channel trays and an
Teyana Taylor you know Tiana coyote a
litera baby [ __ ] I love her so much
and I've been able to talk to her yeah
so it's like this inspires me the young
have the energy and they have the
ability to make me feel inspired and I
love that and I hope I will never stop
doing that I appreciate it thank you I
appreciate this movie you guys job like
everybody I can't wait till the world
gets to see it thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]